[Music]
hi guys so this is a slightly more
informal video than I normally do but I
just had to cover 2019 serenity which
arguably has the worst movie twist of
all time in it
don't worry fans a Firefly this has
nothing to do with the other serenity
movie and if you're smart you'll stay
well away from this there's of course
going to be huge spoilers in this video
but I imagine if you're watching this
that you've already seen the Rotten
Tomatoes score for the film so you don't
really care anyway with that out of the
way I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I watch it so you don't
have to
serenity centers around fishermen baker
dill who lives on a fishing Island
called Plymouth no fellow Brits not that
Plymouth though there are probably about
the same amount of boats
anyway throughout the film the character
receives strange visions but if he could
really tell the future then he wouldn't
have greenlit this movie where anyway
dil is an Iraq war veteran and now makes
ends meet by taking people out on his
boat named serenity there's a whole
prostitution subplot that I don't really
want to get into that basically paints
out that dill is broke ah he needs to
get some dildo like dildo like money I
approached her mother
anyway the woman that he regularly
sleeps with has a son that dill says is
welcome to come back and work on his
boat once more as you'll give him a job
even though he doesn't have any money
which he did look this aspect of the
movie probably makes the most sense out
of everything else anyway
throughout the film dill is tracked down
by his ex-wife Karen and left him for a
rich man because why not
and now she wants dill to kill him
because he's an abusive husband Karen
and Frank as he's called have a son
together who likes to play video games
which normally I wouldn't cover that
kind of pointless detail in a video but
it plays massively into the stupid twist
so yep it's in there anyway Karen and
her husband are going to be having a
holiday on the island and the former
ones del to kill him and dump his body
into the ocean
something Dell refuses this but he keeps
getting visions of their son Patrick
sitting in his room playing video games
you wouldn't know what games you could
be playing on instead this weekend
I mean Resident Evil 2 is out that's a
good one make sure you watch my video on
Resident Evil 2 yeah safe anyway Karen's
husband Frank shows up they go for a
trip which is when he tells Baker that
his son Patrick loves playing fishing
games for some stupid reason you mustn't
know that Resident Evil twos out anyway
he loves playing those fishing games and
that place into the end this businessman
who's been chasing dil down for the
whole movie finally catches up with him
and gives him this fishfinder radar
thing that dil can use to catch a
massive tuna which throughout the film's
all that he's really really wanted and
he's finally gonna get it guys yeah the
businessman called Reed doesn't really
seem to want anything in return for
giving him this tech and he says he's
just playing his part in the game to get
it game listen closely it's a bit all a
big game anyway didn't it turns out that
this entire island is actually part of a
video game that's it I'm not lying bill
is a video game character in a fishing
game it turns out that Karen's son
Patrick is the programmer and that he's
making this simulation we find out that
the real dill died in a rack and that
his son Patrick's reprogrammed a fishing
game to live out a fantasy of killing
his abusive stepfather dill kind of goes
back and forth on whether to kill M&R
and the island really try to rally
together to stop him from doing it
because they just want to go back to
playing the game you know plain catching
lovely big tunas and stuff like it used
to be in the good old days anyway
because of video games of violent and
turned people into murderers apparently
for some reason it dill decides to kill
the father and then we cook to the real
world where Patrick it turns out he's
actually killed his abusive stepfather
during another one of his attacks
just ridiculous really we learned that
Patrick withdrew into this digital world
and created a paradise and because of
this and the whole self-defense thing
with his abusive father he's pretty much
gotten away with murder and the movie
ends with Patrick and ring the digital
world where he embraces with his father
which indicates that Patrick has made a
digital version of himself to spend time
with his dad like he never got to in the
real world it's so touching I mean just
brilliant to screen right in there
basically it's just a big mess like
twists can often make a break movies and
this one does the latter I get what they
were going forward the whole making a
real father to replace his step one but
it's it's just terrible I've got a lot
of hate for saying that I enjoyed
replicas so I want some apologies from
you guys here cuz sheesh this is the
worst movie of the year
I don't want to hear anything about our
beloved Keanu Reeves anyway let me know
your thoughts on the film in the
comments below and if you enjoyed this
video then please like it and make sure
you check out my breakdown of Resident
Evil 2 remake at the end of this video
which it's inspired me it go kill some
zombies yeah this is a channel for
people who are mad into movies so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this sorry oh went into a
bit of a rant but I hope you enjoyed it
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]